la morsa y la actualidad internacional
se dieron cita en la inauguración del
festival de cannes
el festival de cine más grande del mundo
se inauguró en el pequeño balneario de
cannes como siempre con una lluvia de
estrellas del séptimo arte mundial que
desfilaron por la alfombra roja y
posaron para los fotógrafos
[Música]
te abrió así la edición número 75 del
festival de cannes cita que no cerró los
ojos ante la guerra en ucrania y
permitió que el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski tomará la palabra
para hablar del poder del cine y
denunciar una vez más la invasión rusa a
su país
la velada concluyó con la proyección
fuera de la competencia de la cinta
final coach del francés michel
hazanavicius cinta hilarante que cuenta
el rodaje de una película de zombies de
tercera categoría
pero mucho
realiza su firme el hecho de haber
filmado esta película luego de la
pandemia y de reírnos como niños con
escenas o chistes tontos ligeros nos
permitió liberar toda esta tensión y nos
hizo mucho bien a todos y quizás la
gente tiene set de comedia estoy muy
feliz de traer un poco de felicidad
estamos viviendo momentos muy difíciles
pero no podemos dejar de
esta cosa yo veo muy poco vaina el coche
es la versión francesa hay una cinta
japonesa de muertos vivientes pero
detrás de la profusión de sangre y de
decapitaciones es también una carta de
amor al cine y al caótico complicado y
apasionado oficio de hacer películas